[Applause]
all right a little bit about me I wrote
my first line of code in 1977 that's not
the most important thing to have in the
1977 the most important thing to have in
1977 with Star Wars so just so we have
our priorities straight that line of
code was written on a trs-80 model one
4k of ram cassette tape player to store
your software on and a version of basic
it was a tiny basic and it only had
three error messages what how and sorry
which I still think one of the best
error messages of all time and not just
because I'm Canadian because it's kind
of honest I mean what is object not
found but sorry I was 10 years old and I
fell in love with computing right then
and I've really never done anything else
since I got lucky I walked into the
right radio shack at the right time and
got enamored of this machine that first
line of code was ten print hello world
close quote all about my second line of
code 20 go to ten and then I learned
about the break key but there's a power
to programming right we're all a kind of
superhero when we learned to develop
software and smart and recent said a
number of years ago software is eating
the world everything is kind of software
driven and for me as a ten-year-old I
wasn't thinking about any of that I just
thought it was cool but as I got older
and this became my career I discovered
you can do pretty much anything you want
in technology just think creatively
explore the possibilities I found a way
to to travel the world to take gigs
based on the fact that they're in a
country I'd never been to that's one
wind choose work because there's always
more work than we can hope to do and it
lets just lots of opportunities and if
you've listened to the podcast earn
enough that you know if I've had a lot
of fun with it and had an opportunity to
help people along the way
well but the first time I really saw
software and disaster response come
together was Katrina
that's 2005 now if you're keeping track
so more than ten years ago Hurricane
Katrina tore up the Gulf Coast
especially New Orleans and that was the
time of the internet at least you know
the dot-com boom had already come and
gone
and we had the internet it was really
the first time you saw the internet
doing its thing groups of people got
together during that crisis and they
created software to help people one of
the most famous aspects was animal
rescue 600,000 pets were abandoned
during Katrina and they had to be
matched to back up with their owners in
fact it's interesting in the United
States at least 2005 in the Katrina
event was a turning point for pets
because a lot of people refused to
abandon their animals and so stayed
while the hurricane was going on and put
themselves in jeopardy as well they're
members of the family and since then
they've now incorporated rescue systems
there's been software ever since I met a
fellow who wrote one of the apps that
people were using to try and match up
lost animals with their owners and he
talked about the ruff a building
software to save little furry live and
but also the reality that at the end of
the event when things have basically
handled the software bought lost as
software does some time and he got to
write that same app again a few years
later for a different hurricane and then
he wrote it again for another hurricane
and he turns out he gets really good at
writing that out but it made me think
you know we could probably be a bit more
efficient in that respect what does it
take to make really sustainable software
and that's an interesting concept
typically we're paid to write software
and ultimately we don't own it we are
writing it on behalf of someone else and
they're ultimately responsible for its
sustainment but you know as well as I do
when you leave when you stop working on
that particular piece of software
it's vulnerable it's hard to keep the
piece of software alive when the core
people that wrote it aren't involved
anymore alright something that's still
buildable so please still modifiable
still audible something that can be
sustained now in 2012 I was looking at
how to help software developers be able
to volunteer the time to charity because
I know and you know that software's not
actually free doesn't matter if you give
the software free away software is free
the same way of copy is free and people
have to live with software and if you
donate your time to a charity to create
something they have to live with that
maybe it's a weekend sprint where you
you create a brochure where website at
the end of that weekend you get to go
home but the charity has to continue to
operate that software and so if I wanted
to allow developers to be able to
exercise their skills to help people the
real challenge is how do we allow you to
be able to stop and be able to come back
to it later sustain that software
between those times that we're able to
do volunteerism and one of the things
that's happened in the past few years I
think is very important is open source
open source sort of acknowledges this
idea that the source codes not the asset
you know one would argue the ability to
build it is a bit more important aspect
of that but open source confuses folks
that aren't in this space let me get
this straight that's a Daniel pink said
this extremely well you work all day
writing code and then when you go home
at night you write or code for free and
in Daniel Pink's Drive he talked about
why that works why that goes on and I
think it's one of the reasons that has
made humanitarian toebox possible which
is this idea that there's more to the
creative act to the exercising of our
super power when it comes to software
than what we get paid to write it Daniel
talked about three things you talked
about autonomy the ability to choose
whose what you work on how you work
what's important to you in that creative
endeavor of creating of making code they
also talked about mastery because no
software is perfect right same as
playing music you can always play the
song a little better or a little
differently there's more to it
I've met developers who are very upset
when the project is done I really like
that code I'd like to keep working on
that code Morstan could happen as the
project had been finished you know James
Joyce said art has never finished only
abandoned I met a lot of software like
that too we want to keep working on that
we want to keep policy and keep
exploring it that was the second asset
that Daniel pink talked about the third
one is purpose so purpose really speaks
to why software important to you what
are you working on that matter student
it's what's made the open-source
community sort of thrive has been that
I'm working on something that matters to
me now an awful lot of open source
software is by developers for developers
sites internal tooling it's resourcing
and we collaborate around those projects
somebody has an inspired idea and puts
it out for all of us to explore then we
contribute to it it's part of our
community but if we start thinking in
the broader sense of what charity can do
for that with that it's even more
powerful we can go further but if a
couple of other elements especially if
we think all the way back to something
like Katrina we really want to create
sustainable software for charities we
need infrastructure the good news is
since then we've gotten the cloud so we
have a public computing infrastructure
available to us that we can push work to
at any time and I would also argue that
a very important part is everybody has a
computer now you know we may talk about
the post PC era but these devices have
as much horsepower as pcs of just a few
years ago if not more I did the math the
other day in the iPad 2 has the same
gigaflop processing power as the Cray
XMP from 1985 of course the Cray XMP
modeled nuclear explosions in the ipad2
place candy crush
but close enough so it's a combination
of these things
the idea of creating sustainable
software through an open-source
community using the cloud and mobile
devices that create a humanitarian tool
box and that's our tagline when disaster
strikes save lives the same way that
that Marc Andreessen said software's
eating the world
I would argue software could save the
world now I know fair bit about software
I've been doing it for a long time and
I've worked in the community for a long
time
but I have had to learn about charity
and about Disaster Response and we chose
disaster response because there's many
places where software can help in
charities if you think about the idea of
just bringing cloud and mobile to
organizations throughout the world which
a lot of us are doing anyway for our
businesses but you think of it then the
aspects of actually trying to help the
world there's a lot we can do I chose
Disaster Response because it was
everywhere in the world natural
disasters are an equal opportunity
destroyer doesn't really matter where
you go folks are impacted by that and
there are developers all over the world
that want to help so let's get a mission
that actually covers enough things but
as I spent time with disaster relief
workers and folks who really know this
space I've gotten another mantra from it
this actually comes to my friend Jim
McGowan of the Red Cross he said we need
to focus on outcomes not outputs
what's an outcome an outcome is a life
saved right an output there's some lines
of code and it's easy to focus on
outputs because those tend to be the
things we do where outcomes are what
happens from the things we do and it's
harder to think about those things and
I've been focused a lot on how do we
measure outcomes rather than output so
it's not enough to just write code that
code has to work and it has to be used
in a meaningful way that actually
creates an outcome that's important so
we started back in 2012 we actually
became a registered US charity in 2014
and we've been working on projects ever
since and I'd love to talk to you about
a couple
them Disaster Response is an interesting
space and it's also evolving so one of
the projects I could talk about is
called the check-in service or crisis
check-in and it speaks is this idea that
when a major national disaster occurs a
lot of people descend on that site to
help now a couple of decades of code
that would be a half a dozen
organizations mostly governmental that
would arrive and coordinate with each
other to do the key things that happen
that need to happen in a disaster
response saving lives protecting folks
that are harmed get them into safety
start restoring their homes get them
back to their normal lives right those
first few things happen in a matter of
days later after that it can be months
or even years to complete that recovery
but I would partly blame the internet
for this but generally I would blame
activism as a whole today when you talk
about a major disaster
it is literally hundreds of
organizations with thousands of
volunteers that arise on a site and
organizing them is not a small problem
now these organizations tend to be
vertically integrated siloed so for
example you talk about an organization
like stocks Without Borders an
extraordinary group of people fantastic
organization mostly has doctors oddly
enough and that's great they come with
their own portable hospitals you're
talking about a major disaster site but
when you actually talk about mitigating
a disaster you have to reorganize folks
into teams so that's going to be some
engineers that is going to be some
medical skills that's going to be some
volunteer types that can fill sandbags
and do heavy lifting and operate
machinery and so forth this composing of
teams takes time it's an organizational
challenge especially when you're talking
about the sheer size of a major disaster
site and I scrounge the internet for
some pictures of what it looks like to
organize this without technology the way
it's always been described to me is
whiteboards and post-it notes this
actual picture by the way is the command
center for the Fukushima disaster in
the app we've been building for the past
two years
it's called crisis check-in and you'll
see it's been written by developers not
user interfaces on us and our sponsor of
this project is the organization called
the national voluntary organizations
active in disaster or nvivo ad and we've
actually had this app out in virtual
field trial so one of the challenges
when you're working in disaster
responses you don't get to just give
them software you have to go through a
series of trials to prove its validity
and typically you're competing against
technologies like pen and paper which
doesn't sound that hard until you
measure battery life does the battery
life on pen and paper is pretty awesome
resolution is pretty good too and
disaster response folks are conservative
they're careful they need their things
to work they're going to be in adverse
conditions and so stability reliability
all those things are important so we are
still in the process of testing this
particular piece of software and showing
that it has capabilities that matter
what's fun about this particular piece
is that another thing is emerging from
this because we all have these digital
extensions to our bodies the smart
phones now one of the opportunities is
to increase data flow so it's one thing
after say an earthquake to get out
they're trying to stack tall buildings
for structural damage for bridge damage
for services ruptured gas lines leaking
and so forth and there are qualified
people that can do that so there's only
so many of them it takes time to
organize them get them out there and yet
every citizen for the most part in many
parts of the world has a camera and a
piece of technology and they generally
come to GPS data to boot could we start
capturing that data and feed it into a
system to do faster disaster assessments
to look at a larger picture of what's
going or at least to know with the
limited skilled resources we have where
this should look first and so one of the
features we're exploring now is that
social media data collection not even
counting on the citizens to direct it to
us but
just out in Twitter if we were just
watching what folks are taking pictures
of what they're concerned about what the
conversations are going on so we can
plug into that and help to coordinate
and organize that information this is a
force multiplier that's what we actually
do in software fact it's all we've ever
done in software if you think about it I
would describe this to a non-technical
CEO it says software and computers are
only amplifiers they can amplify your
intelligence or they can amplify your
stupidity let me know which one you want
this is an interesting force multiplier
that we can allow a hat a large diverse
dispersed group of people to gather data
for us so that we can respond faster get
to where we need to be sooner to get
people back to their regular lives more
quickly
that's what check-in is all about the
project that we worked on this week is
project called already now already is
more of a preparatory project it's fun
to think focus to focus on disaster
response but it's not the only element
to it and disaster response software is
you're a challenging to write it's very
interesting right - right we have to
contend with different things you know
one of the conversations is always well
we can't use smart phones after a
disaster because the cell networks don't
work which is not necessarily true
because while the cell networks never
worked perfectly ever they never failed
completely either they're remarkably
resilient in adverse conditions they
could take a beating and some of it will
still function and in fact these days
most disasters Fonts organizations are
highly motivated to take advantage of
cell technology because generally where
you find a phone and disaster site
there's a person needs help beside us
and so they'll even bring in portable
cell towers trucks with expanding masks
on top of them and generators so they
can stand up a cell node on-demand and
so you can locate those phones while we
still have power and get to the people
that need to help and then disaster
response workers can leverage that
network to gather additional data so I
know we're thinking because we're all
developers here about how would I
implement this what would I think about
on this
can't help ourselves or suck a disease
one of the fun parts about doing this is
dealing with a damaged network you can't
count on 4G I mean you can't count on 4G
on good days but on bad days when you
can't count on 4G you could still
transmit data I'll be it slowly and
carefully over SMS if you had to you
know but 100 characters are to go so one
of the challenges we have playing with
the software it's given a damage network
could we still move a meaning the
critical data around them let's less
pictures and video but more core
messages core contacts you know
identifying localities GPS data we could
actually do a little out with those
networks it's a different way to think
about software to deal with that
sustainability and resiliency aspects of
keeping that stuff running so the cell
network is still being a vital part of
the equation already came along a little
later than the crisis check it out
already but has a sponsor in the Red
Cross now they're not paying for it this
is a volunteer effort right all of our
software development is done by
volunteers and they what we need a
sponsor we need somebody who knows what
needs to be built right a domain expert
it's no different than any other piece
of software and in this particular case
the project was really about utilizing
volunteers efficiently how do I make
sure that when someone volunteers their
time we do is we make sure they make as
big a difference as possible and it's
been a mission for me now working in
manicuring toolbox as well if you're
going to write code for me how do I make
sure that that you feel like we've spent
your time wisely I mean I'm thrilled to
death that you donated a day or a half a
day or a few hours to one of our
projects how do I make sure that you can
actually work on something meaningful
which it's all about organizing right
make sure we use that time efficiently
so already is more of a preventative Lee
focused app the case study the thing
we're actually building right now for
the red working with the Red Cross on
this is putting smoke detectors into
homes that need them these are often
low-income homes but there's a variety
reasons why someone might not have a
smoke detector or and I'll have a smoke
detector that works and smoke detectors
are not expensive and they save lives
there's no two ways about it and in
North America
the Red Cross has groups of volunteers
that will go to a house fire where the
family is displaced there are all
volunteers that go to these things is a
difficulty arises flanked 'its and teddy
bears cell phone numbers and contacts if
you've got a family standing out on the
street watching their house burn they've
probably got a little bit of stress and
it's good to have someone DIC and help
direct them to what happens next and how
they get going from there and the Red
Cross is remarkably competent and
capable of these things their volunteers
are extraordinarily compassionate people
that make all of that work but they'd
rather be out of the business they'd
rather that fire never got to that point
right that it was only smouldering when
the smoke alarm went off and they could
put it out themselves to stop it from
being severe be on top of that it
certainly makes sure everyone gets out a
lot the smoke detectors are inexpensive
the only tricky part about a smoke
detector is installing it correctly
there are some rules about the right
place to put it they mostly involve
being just out of reach you can't turn
it off when you burn your food but you
need a volunteer who knows how to
install them correctly and so they run
they need to run these campaigns they'll
typically be at a at a home depot or
some kind of a large shopping mall with
signs and tables and volunteers saying
do you need a smoke detectors we come in
and replace yours for you and they'll
collect those names and addresses and
then organize their volunteers to go to
install them some weeks later not a
hugely complicated task but software can
make a huge difference in this that we
can manage that came and campaign in
more detail keep grout track of that
geographical data and then when it comes
to the actual installers there's less
manual labor involved they don't have to
all come into one place and get a list
of names and address and so forth now we
can do it with their phone and just to
make it a little more interesting we tie
into technology like Twilio so that when
the Installer is ready to go to a
particular home they can hit a button on
that app that then notifies the home
owner we're on their way we're on a way
to put that smoke ejector in just the
way the cable company doesn't we notice
a difference in the trials on this
because typically if you've got several
weeks delay between the time where he
said yes I'd like a free smoke detector
installed in my home and someone
actually showing up do you want to give
me about 20
thirty percent result of being
successfully installed people forget
they're not home they don't know who the
strange man is at the door there's a lot
of reasons why it doesn't actually
install but when we use the technology
so that we reminding people when we're
coming who's going to be coming what
they can expect that success rate goes
up to more like 80 percent and so more
smoke detectors get solved in less time
and using those volunteers time more
efficiently and we get to focus on
outcomes rather than the outputs the
output is the installing of the smoke
detector which is a good output no two
ways about it the outcome will be the
house fires didn't happen or the
housewives are got managed better so
part of our effort in the software is
actually to monitor these sorts of
things in detail the good folks here at
NBC offered up one of their workshop
rooms over the past couple of days so
that we could do a little coda song
around already and we had about a dozen
people come out and work on the project
and put a few pull requests in a move
that Neal forward I would do it I have
to give around applause to Jake in the
team like thank you so much for the
space and they fed us it's nice it was a
good it was a great project and it also
has some styling challenges so when we
talk about the help that we need UX
folks please we're nice developers we
managed to pick up some orange but that
was about as much styling we've done so
far this apps almost ready to go into
production we're going to put it into
the field
if this month we expect so the feature
sets matured and we've done enough
testing and trials with it different
organizations that we're now having some
confidence that we can put it on the
field and something new that's come up
for us is we're running it in the cloud
so Microsoft philanthropies is a part of
a Microsoft organization that's involved
in giving public cloud for public good
and so we're now a member and they're
pretty much giving us as much as sure as
we need to actually operate the software
when we started humanitarian tool box we
were thinking in terms of we're going to
make a tool box of software that people
can run when they need it and that's you
know the toolkit side of it now it's
starting to look like disaster response
as a service so how about I just run it
for you so you don't have to worry about
setting it up and installing it and
maintaining it so forth
operating the cloud on your behalf in a
multi tendency app form and when your
project winds down will they will just
hang on to it for you and if other
people need to run them we can run them
all in parallel so I have a sneaking
suspicion this particular app will never
get turned off we'll keep adding to it
if you think about the scenario I've
just painted here there are many other
applications we're already talking to an
organization and wants to do flood
prevention checking so would you like a
free inspection to make sure that your
house is prepared in case of severe
rains and flooding right what resources
are available what can be done same
thing skilled volunteers need to do is
inspecting we can organize them so they
utilize their time effectively and you
can get those checks done so that you
have some confidence that you're going
to know what will happen to you in a
flood and the list goes on with this
project so this software is all built
out in the open it's sitting on github
if you'd like a copy
knock yourself out feel free you want to
contribute also feel free when we're not
restricting access to any of these
things you can do anything you want with
any of it
so we're looking at other projects and
other opportunities where we can utilize
the same software to solve related
problems mostly about prevention in
serious disasters there's a lot of ways
that this can be utilized and there's
many more projects you can think of up
until now if you're generally mulling
over this idea that's like there's a lot
of apps we could be building right
disasters are complicated beasts there's
many things that could be contributed a
lot of projects to be done and typically
in the open-source community the
approach to projects is very much driven
by the developer what idea do you have
today maybe would and we'll talk about
it and add the feature in we've not
approached open source that way we're
working with disaster response experts
and good project managers that allow us
to break the work down into coherent
work items so that you don't have to
invent the best solution of the problem
we've got to work item four you pick it
up and run with it and I've been really
pleased to see the kind of community
that has grown around our project this
already project now has a hundred and
fifteen contributors at about 2,700
commits over the past 18 months
but there's no sort of dominant
developer in this project you know most
open-source projects have ever seen
really are the vision of an individual
who's done the bulk of their conscious
the bulk of the contributions and then a
few other folks get involved if you look
at the top contributors to already
you'll see it's about ten people that
are all have a hundred plus contribution
so that commits to the project and
that's sort of driven it and then
there's many many more that have done a
few commits we hold coda songs on a
regular basis NDC's that just hosted
ours this past two days and we love the
work that comes from that we our mission
always when you come in and work on a
coda song with us is that you'll get a
check in or two down in those two days
but what we're really hoping is you get
hooked on our project right I think back
to Daniel Pink's autonomy mastery
purpose I think we got a lot of purpose
here and the economy and mastery is
completely up to you on what you want to
work on already built with asp.net core
so we are you know playing with the
leading-edge bits maybe that stuff you
can't use in your work yet but you'd
like to experiment with it I have a
project for you it's something you could
contribute to and continue to contribute
to and so we've had the experience where
three friends came into a codeathon in
Wisconsin worked for two days with us on
a project and said you know we used to
go bowling on Wednesdays now we pick up
already work items and just continue to
contribute to the project so those
long-term contributors that's where they
come from I'm going to embarrass him I
don't think he's in the room but Steve
Gordon is one of our contributors from
here in the UK I met him for the first
time this week at the at this event he
just came out of the blue one day we
were operated and we were we've got a
group of folks in different locations
work on the project and one day we
started getting pull requests from the
UK he had heard about us heard about
humanitarian toolbox on Donna rocks and
he had picked up the project it's
thought already was pretty cool and he
just started making contributions and
he's one of our top contributors at this
point and he was able to meet us that
this week but also brought his whole
team along so the five of them worked
together on that project and it's one of
the things that I think is the most
exciting when you talk about these kinds
of contributions
I've done team-building exercise with
software developers literally for
decades I because I firmly believe a
really productive team those team
members trust each other and it's fairly
hard to build up trust at work
you got to work in other environments
got to sort of see people out of their
normal element to really get a sense of
who they are and so what I'd end up
doing is taking my team off to do
charitable works but we usually end up
at a place like you have caps of
humanity an awesome charity they do
amazing work good fun to work on it but
it is a little frustrating DC and
extraordinary back-end programmer
painting offense now the defense didn't
need to be painted and not that he
didn't do a good job but was really the
best thing we could do with the half-day
that we had to work together watching
Steve's team develop together these past
two days days on a project it's not part
of their normal thing with tooling they
don't normally use but really enjoying
each other and press against each
other's skills and exploring things and
making sure everybody got a pull request
and very inspirational to me to see that
this is what we can do as citizens of
the world and software developers to
actually work together to be better as
developers as well as making substantial
control contribution if you want a
picture of just how many people that
looks like it looks like this these are
the contributors to already and this is
the guys from the past two days at Steve
on the right there
thank you Steve and a bunch of his team
it's people writing software right we're
helping them to make sure they're
working on the right thing we just
organize the project keep the work items
flowing some easier ones some harder
ones we explore ideas together and one
of the talking points over the past two
days has been we need to manage multiple
identities so we're going to talk to
Dominic and and Brock about identity
server as the right way to manage
identities across multiple apps you get
to explore those technologies and one of
the fun parts for us on this project is
because of this community when we ran
into issues with times
who do we call John skeet if he's pretty
much the only got on the planet actually
understands them and John being John
just jumped into our slack Channel for a
half an hour and talked through the
problem and how we'd use no to time for
it and helped us move forward and after
he was gone the team members were like
was that really John ski since I guess
we just had to drive by guy John skeet
when you work on these guides of
projects you get an amazing group of
people to come out and get involved with
it and there's so much more to build
we're coming into v1 with already crisis
check-in needs to do through a couple
more trials before it can possibly go in
the field I've held us down to just a
couple of projects because I know I need
to focus on outcomes not output we could
have run many projects at once but it
slows down the outcomes so we're now
coming into an important set of outcomes
we're going to light up more projects
and we could use as much help as we can
find if you would like to get involved
with us HT boss org is the website we
also own humanitarian toolbox comm so if
you know how to spell humanitarian
that's another way to get to the site
we're on github the projects through
there you can take a look at them you
don't have to deal with us you can just
go straight through github for
everything we have a Twitter handle
that's my Twitter handle as well you'll
see me talk about this and worry about
this on a regular basis
we can use your help there is so much
code to write and there are many more
outcomes we need to achieve and I hope
you'll be a part of it have a great NDC
thank you so much for coming out to see
us and I'll see you all week thank you